- So,
my name is Shaletia
and this is my lifetime story.
Growing up in the state
of Louisiana, Baton Rouge
at the age of 10.
Going through the tragic
of being molested.
Got molested and moved out of the house
where I was getting molested at.
Child Protection came and picked me up.
I went from foster home to foster home,
getting beaten, getting mistreated.
After I got from foster
home to foster home,
my grandmother decided to come pick me up
and take care of me.
So I went to stay with one grandmother.
She took care of me for a couple of years
and then I went from her
to the other grandmother.
Never was raised by my mom.
My mom was on drugs.
My father had passed
away at the age of 29.
Living the life with them,
it was pretty good.
I was raised pretty
good by my grandmothers.
Had tough love.
Then I got out there in the
streets at the age of 16.
Started fighting, getting
put out of school.
Didn't felt loved.
Didn't felt understood.
Well as I grew up to the age of 17,
I had my first daughter.
Moved out of my grandmother
house, moved in my own place.
Tried to start a new life, new beginning.
Started working and doing
pretty good then I fell off.
I started getting on pills,
started popping pills, ecstasies
and getting high off of narcos.
And that just led to a bad addiction.
Well, that addiction
drove me to sell my body.
I started to sleep with older men.
(Shaletia sighs)
It was just tragic.
It was tragic for me.
This whole life of me
living was very tragic.
It was real.
I almost think I wouldn't gonna make it.
But as the years passed, I grew up.
Age 18, I had my second daughter.
Living with my baby daddy, he beat me,
mistreating me, dogging me.
I steady stayed with him
and we moved in together.
I trusted him so much.
I woke up one morning
and see him on the couch
with my 14 year old sister.
So that me down another road.
So as I go down that road,
my sister winds up being pregnant.
At the age of 14, I had to
tell her take care of the baby.
So after he did that to me,
went into the next life
of trying to do better and
be with someone better.
And I left my kids with my baby daddy.
He raped my daughter.
So going through that,
it took me through another loop.
So I got on another drug.
Started smoking weed.
Never was my thing.
So here I'm getting high, trying to work,
trying to take care of my kids by myself.
Trying to make sure I
have a good babysitter
so my daughter wouldn't
go through the things
that she's went through with her father,
him raping her from the age of 10 to 16.
I came to California.
Came off in a bad, bad way.
Got out here in the
streets selling my body,
on drugs,
drinking,
partying,
nothing with my life.
And I wound up going to
prison, four years flat.
And as I did those four years flat,
I thought I wasn't gon'
never get out of there.
But God opened up a door for me
to be able to get out of prison.
I got out of prison, but I
started back down that same road.
Popping pills,
smoking weed,
drinking.
And I thought to myself, "You know what?
"I'm tired.
"It's time for a change.
"It's time for me to
do something different.
"I'm in a new city, new state.
"It's better living,
"than life I lived in Louisiana
"being from foster home to foster home,
"house to house,
"molested at the age of 10."
I said, "I'ma try something
different, accept help."
I started to accept help here.
Going back and forth to the mission.
Standing in the line with a walking cane.
Barely can walk.
So many health problems.
Diabetes,
pinched nerve,
doctor wanted to take me through surgery.
I'm in and out the doctor's
office getting injections
and going through all kinds
of treatment and everything.
Trying to get better, trying
to get my mind better,
mentally unstable.
Well as I started to get to treatment,
and started to go to the doctors,
and started to receive all the medications
that they put me on and everything...
'Cause I was out of whack, out of whack,
out of mind, for so many
things that I went through.
Going from state to state,
trying to find a way.
Trying to find a better life.
I found one here.
I began to receive the treatment
and began to receive the counseling
and the phone calls of prayers.
And my great uncle,
Edward Haze,
he's been helping me ever
since I've been here.
He's helped me keep my mind stable.
Without him, I don't know
what I would have done.
He helped me
do so many things that
I thought I couldn't do.
Helped me got housing,
helped me to straighten up my mind
why I wouldn't be out
there on drugs anymore.
Didn't have the urge of it.
Didn't want it and still don't want it.
But I'm still on it.
Still on pain pills, still popping pills.
Still doing the drinking.
Just don't wanna give it up.
This is a lifestyle.
But living this life here,
has been much better.
I am housed now,
I have a car,
but I still have a drug habit.
Still popping pills, day
after day, day after day.
Still struggling being raped down here,
living in tent,
on Skid Row.
Sleeping on the ground
with just a blanket.
Going through everything
everybody else going through.
The homelessness, been there,
still going through it.
Still striving.
Still trying to do the
best that I can to live.
But I'm still doing the same thing.
The same thing.
Selling drugs, taking drugs.
Everything possible to be high,
to numb all the pain
and the suffering that I'm going through.
Don't know which way to
go or what to do no more.
I feel the drug is what makes me happy.
So I constantly takes it every day.
Then when I wake up, drugs,
go to sleep, drugs.
That's the only thing make
me have a stable mind now.
So many people don't
know what I go through.
Never ask.
I go through so much
life fulfilling things.
My daughter's in another state.
My grandbaby, in another state.
I'm unable to see 'em on parole.
Thanks today I just got off of parole.
So I give my thanks to God for that.
But I still haven't changed anything.
I'm still the same person.
I'm still doing the same things.
Do I wanna change?
Not really.
I'm comfortable what I'm doing.
But what I wish I could have changed
is my daughter being raped by her father,
her father sleeping with my
other sisters, molesting them.
If I could change that,
that would mean the world to me.
But I can't.
Wanna do something to him?
Yes.
Angry?
Oh yes.
Definitely angry.
I'm so angry with not just him but myself
because I allow all
these things to happen.
All this pattern, this
curse over the family.
All my family was on drugs.
Nobody can help me get off of drugs
'cause they're on drugs.
Shooting dope, smoking dope,
smoking weed, selling drugs.
All kind of things.
Never seen it in my life
that family would have you
selling drugs for them.
I hit off.
I've sold pills from the age
of 16 all the way up to now,
and I'm 38 years old.
I want a new life
but I don't know how to get that new life.
I don't know how to get that new life.
I don't know where to find it at.
Just being a person that
I am, I have a good heart,
but I go through so much.
So much pain.
So much suffering every day.
Just knowing that I can
change my life around
with the blink of a eye.
But I just won't.
I speak to my uncle every day.
He's my encouragement.
But he doesn't know half of
the things that I go through.
Being abused,
being raped,
being molested.
People don't believe nothing that I say.
They always think I'm a liar,
or I'm just sugarcoating things
making it seem like
things has happened to me
and they have it.
No, this is the real me.
This is me.
This is what you're gonna get.
And I've been trying to
tell my family for so long.
I have issues.
I have problems.
I have mental issues.
I've been wanting to
go homicidal on people.
I've been wanting to go suicide on people.
People just don't know what I go through.
But by the grace of God,
He's kept me from doing things.
From doing things to myself,
doing things to others.
So I just medicate myself with drugs.
When I pop a pain pill,
I don't feel nothing.
I don't hear nothing.
I don't see nothing.
I'm just high.
And I feel good.
Am I gonna stop being on drugs?
No.
'Cause all drugs is a drug.
Any drug you take is a drug.
And me just popping pain pills what it do?
It numbs me.
It numbs all the pain and the suffering
and the heartache that I go through.
Losing the family members, people,
all my family members dying.
If they're not dying from health issues
they're dying from drugs.
Been on drugs for years.
Am I tired?
Not yet.
I'm not ready to throw the towel in yet.
But will I try?
Yes,
I will try.
But right now, this is the only thing
that helps me get through
this life on earth.
From going through all
this abuse in my life.
This is the only thing that
helps me, taking a pill.
That's what I live by every day.
That's what I want.
To just know I'm everything
that's happening around me.
All the hatred
and the abuse that people
are issuing out to me.
Not just the physical
abuse, but the mental abuse.
Just saying all kinds
of ugly things to me.
I'm not gonna never be nothing in life.
I'm not gonna never make it.
I'm not gonna never succeed
or success in nothing.
This is what family tells
me, most of the family.
But they never ask me,
"What's wrong.
"How are you feeling today?
"What are you going through?
"Do you need a helping hand?
"Do you need me to do this for you?
"Do you need me to do that for you?
"Do you need me to help you with this?"
Nobody ask me that.
But steady yet,
I go through this selling
my body to make money,
to make ends meet, to pay bills,
pop a pill,
get high off of that pill.
Have sex just to make that dollar,
to make ends for the next bill.
Selling my food stamps.
Doing all kinds of stuff to get pills.
This is what I do.
People don't know a lot about me
because I'm not from this state.
But the people that are here
knows everything about me.
This is me.
This is what you get.
This is the real GG.
Do I like it?
No.
I don't regret it.
But this is my life that I live.
This is who I am.
This is the only way I can know
I'm everything that has happened to me.
Stealing out of stores, stealing
to make ends meet for food.
People don't know what I go through.
Pushing baskets out the store.
This is the life I've lived.
And this is the life I'm living now.
Yes it's got better.
I don't steal out the
stores as much as I used to.
But now,
who knows what I might do next?
I don't know.
I've done so much in this
world to make ends meet.
world to support my habit.
Borrowing money,
selling this, selling that,
just to make sure I have
a pill in my stomach.
Having withdrawals and sickness
and throwing up and everything,
early in the morning.
It's just what happens.
This is my lifestyle.
This is what I live.
This is what I look up to every day.
Drugs,
money.
This is me.
I don't feel bad.
I don't feel sorry for nothing I do.
Take it or leave it.
This is me.
Yes I'm bitter.
Very bitter.
But I don't know I'm a strong person.
Have I succeeded in a lot of things?
Yes I have.
I got my own place to live in.
I'm not sleeping on the
side of the road no more.
Sleeping in a blanket on the
side of the road, cold, hungry,
walking bare footed, half naked.
Do my family know what I went through?
No.
Going from state to state, mentally ill.
Losing a grandmother,
then go back and lose another grandmother.
These are the only people that raised me.
The only people that
raised me, I look up to,
they're gone.
This has made my drug habit more stronger.
This has made my addiction to
sell my body, to get the drug.
All this has made me grow
stronger into doing it
because of the loss of my grandmothers.
But nobody ever took the
chance to even ask how I feel.
The family members that are
still alive don't call me.
Don't check on me.
Don't see how I'm doing.
They don't care.
Do they care I'm on pills?
No.
Do they care that I sell everything?
Do they care about borrow money?
No.
Get in debt?
They don't care.
But I know it's gonna be a
change now that I have my place,
now that I have my car that
my uncle has blessed me with.
I know that it will be
a change in my life,
one day,
but it's not gonna be no time soon.
This is what I'm gonna do for a while.
I don't know what to look up to no more.
Sometime I don't even
believe there's a God.
And man I know I may be wrong.
But sometime I believe, where is God?
Why He haven't picked me up yet?
Why did He haven't put His hands on me?
Why?
Why He haven't turned my life around yet?
Why am I still struggling
and still fighting against these demons?
These drug demons,
these money demons.
Why am I still fighting against this?
Why do I still feel alone?
No family members to make
me feel no different.
My kids, they try to be there for me.
I be afraid to tell them, "Momma on pills.
"Momma got a drug habit."
I be afraid to tell 'em that.
How would they look at me?
"Well, we have nobody to look up to.
"Daddy, he's a rapist.
"Now you' on pills and on drugs?
"Who we have to look up to."
I can't do that to my kids.
I have to make a difference.
I have to make a better life for myself.
I know the things that I do are not right,
but better yet, I still do them.
I know the lifestyle that I'm living.
I need to change it.
But better yet, I haven't.
I know the hurt and the pain.
I need to give it up to God
and put it in His hands.
But I haven't found that peace yet.
I know
the back history
of selling drugs,
selling my body to make ends meet,
selling my body to get that drug.
I know I need to stop.
But have I put force into stopping?
No.
I don't feel that I'm
strong enough right now.
I don't.
I wish I was strong enough,
but,
with the prayers of God,
just knowing God,
just knowing that He's a God,
I believe I can make it through it.
Maybe some changes will
start to happen for me.
I don't know that.
But with that back history,
can't get a job.
Convicted felony.
All these charges from here to Louisiana.
Of selling drugs, stealing out the stores.
I can't get a decent job.
So what'd I do?
Sell pills
to make ends meet.
to have extra money.
Whatever I can get my hands on, I sell it.
Whatever I could get my hands on,
I sell it and I make money.
That's my life.
I don't no nothing else.
That's the way I was raised.
To sell pills, sell drugs.
Whatever drug you get, sell it.
You make this much amount of money.
That's all I know.
Street life.
Got a little book sense.
Went to school a little
bit, but dropped out
when I had all my kids.
Felt that there was no use
to go to school no more.
This is my school right here, the streets.
I felt the streets had more
love for me than anything.
So what'd I do?
Live street life.
That's where my love come from.
That's all I know.
But you know what?
God is gonna make a way for me.
I'm gonna be able to travel.
I'm gonna be able to do everything
that I possibly wanna
do when I get stronger.
When I get stronger, 'cause
I'm not strong right now.
I need to be strong for my kids
but I just can't right now.
The drugs be calling me,
the pills be calling me.
And sometimes I'll actually
be talking to the pills.
Like they can actually
hear me, which is crazy.
But do I think it's crazy?
No.
I actually think the pills can hear me.
"Baby I love you.
"I love you baby.
"Come into my stomach."
This is how I be talking to the pills.
It's crazy, but it is what it is.
That's what happens when you're on drugs,
you talk to your drugs.
You tell your drugs
what you want 'em to do.
But you know,
I know my life is going to change one day.
I'm being blessed right now.
Had a car accident, about to get paid.
First thing on my mind, "I'm
about to go score something.
"I'm about to go score me a
couple of bottles of pills.
"I'm about to go score me some dope.
"Flip that so I can have
bottles and pills in the house.
"I ain't got to worry about
"going buy no 50 here, 10 here, five here,
"I can go buy a whole bottle."
That's the first thing on my mind.
And do I have any regrets about it?
No,
I don't.
No regrets.
I don't even care about nothing no more.
I feel like this is my life.
No high school diploma.
No GED.
Nothing, nothing to show for.
Just giving a system time after time,
after time, after time.
Just giving a system all of my time.
It's bad.
It's bad for me.
And I know it is.
When I sit and think and
meditate on everything that I do
and to have done in my life,
what have I succeeded in
besides brought beautiful
children to the world?
What have I succeeded?
Have I succeeded in any...
Have I paid for a house or paid for a car?
I haven't succeeded in nothing.
All I do is think about the next pill,
the next dollar,
the next nigga or female,
with a man and a female,
I could lay down on with
Don't care about nothing
Who gon' give me that next
dollar for that next pill?
That's all I care about.
Where I could go pull
up right on the corner
and give me a 10 pack right quick.
That's it.
Sometime I feel like I
gave up on life myself.
I need to have somebody to revise my mind
and let me know that
there is a God out there.
That there are out
there that will help me.
There's a system out
And not the system that
that you'd be behind bars,
but a system that will help me succeed
in getting the education.
Being somebody.
Having a place of business.
Or, I like to cook.
I like to bake.
I love to bake.
I wish that one day I
could open up a bakery
and make the sweets
and the different cakes
and pies and stuff.
The tradition that my grandmother did.
My grandmothers was the
only one that worked hard,
paid for a house, paid
for a brand new car.
And as I grew up looking at the way
they were going about with their life,
I thought to myself, "Am
I gonna be like them?
"Am I gonna live that long age?"
Age 75, both of my
grandmothers passed away.
I lost it.
"Oh, how I'ma do this.
"How I'ma do that.
"Who gon' help me with kids?
"Who gon' do this for me.
"Who gon'..."
I've been on my own.
I'm just throwing back
pills, throwing back pills.
Just numb and everything.
Numb in the fact that they're gone.
My help is gone.
Everybody dying around me.
I'm losing it.
I go into a mental depression.
I'm in a whole nother state
don't know where I'm at.
I'm in a whole nother state and I'm like,
"Where am I?"
"Oh, you're in the State of Washington."
"What I'm doing here?"
"Well you got on the bus ma'am
"and you drove on the bus up here."
"Oh my God, are you serious?
"I just left for a whole house.
"Had a whole apartment in Colorado."
Left it. Walked out and left it.
Came to Washington, Seattle.
Started getting on drugs there.
Start selling my body.
Lost my daughter.
They took my daughter from me.
I'm walking up and down the streets
sleeping under the bridge
and sleeping on sidewalks and stuff.
Walking up and down
the street in the rain.
Trying to figure out who selling pills,
who selling this.
Sleeping with all different
types of men up there.
Left from there came to California,
started doing the same thing.
And it's just been repeatedly,
repeatedly, repeatedly,
every state I stepped foot
in, I do the same thing.
The same thing.
It's time for a change.
It's time for a change within myself.
And I wanna change.
I really do.
But I just feel like I'm
not strong enough right now.
After all I'd been through,
my body been damaged.
I've been disrespected with my body
not only at the age of
10 and at the age of 11,
but the age of 30, raped here.
A man just crawling in my tent,
put a knife to my neck,
told me, "Don't move."
I laid there crying.
Just thinking.
Is this happening all over again to me?
After he finished raping
me, he get up and walk out.
I'm left with that nasty,
ugly feeling all over again.
So now I'm really grinding in the streets.
Really smoking weed, trying to get high.
They' lacing my weed.
I'm on pills, trying to get high,
trying to numb everything all over again.
I'm tired.
I'm tired of the devil chasing me
and I'm trying to chase God.
I'm tired.
I just wish for the best for myself.
And I just hope that my life
do actually change around.
I just got to lose the drug habit
and start getting right with God.
And start getting my mind right.
And get that education.
Thank you.